this program is brought to you by Emory
University
mary lynn morgan has pioneered her way
through life since she was one of the
first female dental students at what
would become the emory dental school to
hear her speak of it it isn't remarkable
that in the 1940s she became one of just
a few practicing female dentists in
Atlanta and after that one of just a few
dentists specializing in pediatric
dentistry now 90 Morgan sees the sense
of accomplishment she gave to children
and their families as more important
than her own achievements even when she
married the influential 1960s Atlanta
journal-constitution editor ralph mcgill
her feet remained solidly on the ground
through it all learning and serving have
been most important to her I'm curious a
little bit about what led you to go to
dental school in the first place I know
that it wasn't very typical in the
nineteen thirties or forties had a log
on my family's came from ardmore
oklahoma just a little time it's a very
bottom of Oklahoma all the way from
Oklahoma City to Dallas and when I was
born and my brother was born both of us
were born in Texarkana Texas and we came
to Florida and that's where we both grew
up I always loved animals and I want to
go to medical school my father already
had this was in a depression my father
had my brother at the University of
Rochester and he said that I just can't
extension a medical school so I liked my
dentist very much and I'd worked in his
office and I thought well that'll be the
second choice it's just lucky that I
liked it as much as I did so your family
it sounds like was very open to you
continuing your education is that right
I never got along well with my mother
because we were so different but I know
that she well I heard her say to a
friend one time we have to educate
Merlin because she's a good student
she's our student
and she was a teacher and was
college-educated and there was just no
question i had to be educated so that
was fun there's a quote from you on the
emory woman center website saying that
it was among a gathering of woman at
Emory talking about mother-daughter
relationships one evening when I begin
to realize just how much my mother had
sacrificed for me to be educated so that
I would have a promising and independent
future the bay make out of that up or
was that do you remember when I was four
years ago I was very ill with master and
took a long time to recover and I said
that what I wanted to do was learn to
read and so she was pretty worn out with
the process of the illness and so I
would fix a chair and a desk and get the
books and when I started to school i
entered the second grade I'd already
been homeschooled even though I wasn't
very old but she was very eager to get
me educated she was and her two sisters
were and that's how that happened it
sounds like you knew this before a lot
of other people did or knew that women
could be or would be just as big of
contributors what do you think helped
you know this so soon well I don't know
that my brother was as I said was a
concert singer and one year a woman
asked him to drive her and her son to
Maine and he wanted to do that because
she had a big car he thought that would
be wonderful but the truck trouble was
that he had to teach the boy first year
algebra before while honest in the
summer truck so he said to me Marilyn
can you teach me first year algebra has
it how much time do we have he said six
weeks I said sure if you pay attention
you know you know first year house was
not very hard and he never paid
attention to Alice if he didn't care
about it but he's sure learned it in a
hurry and I just always had a
respect from my whole family and anybody
else I never thought about women not
being able to do whatever they really
wanted to do mary lynn morgan is not
only one of the first female graduates
of Emrys dental school but one of the
first graduates period when I went to
dental school it was not a part of Emery
maybe you knew that at that time you did
not have to have a bachelor's degree to
go to those who and i'm pretty sure you
do now but when you didn't then anyway I
went to stetson university of florida
and then came to amount of southern
dental college which was not a part of
every he was located on Courtland and
forest avenue we were in that building
of course all the years I was there I
had one summer vacation then we had the
war and so we never stopped I had three
years pushed into plus two summers you
see and either it became a part of Emory
either my senior year or the year after
now when Ali introduces me she always
says my senior year and that might be
right but I think might be the next year
but anyway I was given we were all given
every diploma and then pretty soon I
started teaching so that what women like
to know is when you went to dos go there
were three of us in my class there were
two ahead of us so there were five in
the whole school out of out of how many
students overall there are 102 in my
clothes I think our hundred and three
there were three girls and then in the
junior in the other three classes are
only two girls it sounds like being a
woman never felt like I disadvantage to
you or at least not in dental school
never did are there ways that being a
woman became an advantage during any of
these periods of time that I cannot even
find a situation where it made any
difference at all really
I don't know how to answer that I think
I should disappointment to most people
but I can't Beverly have his men were so
nice to me always yeah well I just
thought that they thought what I said
was as good as anybody said but I never
felt one better discrimination or any
strangeness and never even thought about
it being strange never here and the boys
well we talked about anything everything
so that whole period was just was just
fun and I I never thought about women's
or vs mia after graduation Marilyn
Morgan began a successful career
teaching at emory's dental school and
clinic which has since closed and
working as a pediatric dentist but
anyway we later well i wasn't i think
i've always said this and i was invited
to join the practice of a man whose
mother had been a dentist really in in
Missouri so you see I was no freak to
him that night both of us more
comfortable and I would with him for a
couple of years after I graduated and
then I had a friend in the doctors
building below me Frank wayman's who had
been doing children's dentistry and
orthodontics and he wanted me to come
join his practice so when I told Frank
Johnson with whom I was that that's what
I wanted to do and I had told him before
I ever started and as soon as Frank
lemons was able to make room for me in
build a new office then I went into his
office and
I used to go downstairs and every night
he had a wonderful hygienist who was a
good friend and she would tell me about
patient management if I wasn't sure how
to treat somebody's mother or the child
and that he would tell me about the
procedure that he recommended and
wonderful help so then remember I was in
his office for seven years I think about
that and then I went by myself and the
doctors going and then you had a private
practice therefore until the 1970s is
that right oh let's see I thought I had
these years pretty much in my head god I
was doing 43 uh-huh mummy says she
remembers my year my date of graduation
because of a picture and it was made in
the library on the bottom it says
Marilyn Morgan 43d she thinks that's
very funny because that's like a bra
size so i guess i started my put my own
practice in 54 seems like and I practice
by myself the rest of the rest of my
life until i retired in 76 i started
teaching I would I don't I can't guess
how soon after I graduated but I'd say
through four years and I taught in the
clinic and now the new building on the
campus was not built and I don't know
what year that
but Gary help could tell us exactly when
that would but we talked I taught in the
old building we had no air-conditioning
and when I went into the doctors
building there was no air conditioning
when I moved downstairs with front
layman's it seems to me that we had it
by then because we had a new building
but that was really weird to think back
now about how hot it was particularly on
the top floor that old building downtown
share and we never thought anything
about it but it was just hot of course I
think the South really never imagined it
very much until we did have her
condition we wouldn't have had a city
grow yeah like you saying I know that
one of the distinctions that you've had
as you were named I think man in
dentistry in 1970s yeah the Northern
District down society had an award and I
see I got the third one of the fourth
one they called me when I was in ann
arbor and told me about it and I was
with a rubber friend and he said well
why aren't you happy about I said well I
just don't like the attention I just
don't like to anticipate receiving and
he said well it is there anything wrong
with your ward i said no it's wonderful
i'm thrilled he couldn't understand that
we didn't know why I was not hilarious
but it was fun and he wanted to know if
I wanted him to change it change the
name of it I said no leave it like it is
can you tell us about Lucy and how Lucy
helped in your practice did you see that
Chihuahua and long hair job she was a
nice little smart dog well trained and I
took her to the office and just decided
it would be good for the kids if she sat
in my lap I never had any criticism and
the doctors feeling about having a dog
in the building they all thought she was
cute I had to take her out and during
the day couple down but she just she was
a real help me I couldn't let a child go
into the back room where she was by
herself she'd bitten them but she was
going to behave when she was with them
in the dental chair it was she was real
bright and it sounds like you taught her
that so that she knew that her job was
to sit on his life how did you get any
tile I don't remember but she does she
look at me like um yeah can I get can I
go now yeah that's it she was helpful
how did she help in those cases what how
did she help how did that how did that
work what did it do for the patient I
think anything soft or warm alive is
good for a child I think they need a pet
and to have that little little tiny
animal and the lack was good for him and
it seemed to be to hear mary lynn morgan
speak of her life one major theme
emerges her sense that she has always
been in the right place at the right
time yeah at our first in clinic and
then we had a man who was doing our
children's dental department and he died
what happened to him dr. killers told me
that he wanted me to take the department
and I told him I had no idea to run
department of the University and he said
oh you do too he said besides there's
nobody else to do it you can be but it
wasn't hard what I did that time was
take the most hostile class that I could
think of which was eight o'clock in the
morning sophomores I mean they could not
care what about children's dentistry and
I thought if I can win this the
confidence of this group and I can get
up and do anything you know will pass
out so that was kind of a treat to get
to do that then when I was when and when
I graduated I had this wonderful man
Frank Johnson invited me to come into
his practice I didn't even know him he's
the people's a marvelous man that
beautiful dentistry it just seemed like
it's just happened I was asked to be a
trustee in 75 Henry Bowden came to my
office and then an appointment and we
sat down to talk he invited me to become
a trustee and I said just about that's
really not a very good idea he said well
why you say that I said well number one
I don't have a lot of money and I don't
have access to it now that's a that's a
really important point for a trustee of
any place is that right and I said I
also don't talk very much in a group and
he said well we don't mind that friend
of Jean bird more said Marilyn you were
asked to join the trustees because
you're not a boat rocker I said well
that might be in other words I'm not
yeah I was not aggressive
trying to change anything but is it just
it just seemed to me that just happened
all the time and I've always hard
anyway just has looked like so
many things like that have happened and
people ask me to do get I was present of
the dental alumni and that that was nice
I mean I and I've always been asked to
do so many things like that that I
didn't really go out and work for now
that's quite quite possible I was
married to ralph mcgill it was a
wonderful man and wonderfully known and
I would imagine that it had something to
do with that maybe I don't know you
mentioned um getting married to ralph
mcgill yeah tell us just a man well we
have we had some mutual friends of wife
their children came to me I liked her so
much and then when I started going out
to their house to play with the kids and
and eat and enjoy them and Ralph came to
at various times and so I started taking
him in the Clark and then other places
and because he didn't drive no he didn't
he never did drive he used to like to
ride the bus so he could talk to all of
people and after we were married I went
down there and just picked him up every
afternoon and and I guess I took him to
the office every day I wasn't well as I
can remember anyway we started going
places together he'd like to go he liked
to be at the downtown
club whatever is capital city club on
Saturdays and he liked to go to the
Mirador room and so we would have lunch
and he wanted us to get married and I
thought it wasn't smart to marry
somebody had idolized by reading him for
so many years and he said well maybe we
can change that so we did and we did get
married and we live very happily
together it was wonderful fun and I
enjoyed his son and enjoyed as
everything about it was nice very very
wonderful but he was I forgotten how old
he was when he died but he he was young
and he never had to had to retire he did
that's what he didn't want to do but we
had nice times together he was quite
close to Lyndon Johnson Lyndon Johnson
used him a lot of telephone calls and
stuff like that we went up there to
dinner one night one day for to have
dinner it was kind of a fancy affair it
to honor the president of Tunisia and I
was nervous about going because ralph
said that we would not sit at the same
table and he said well why don't you
study up on Tunisia which I thought that
was a good idea so I did and I sent by a
pilot and I he was impressed and I knew
all the geography tunisia i would never
would have thought of it myself but it
was a happy happy marriage you mentioned
that there was also a time you were
driving down the street with Lyndon and
and Ralph oh oh yes hey I'm the
president said would you like to go out
to wish I could remember the name of
that
Islanders one you would know they were
having some kind of a fair out there so
we went out with him and and there were
people on both sides of the street when
his car came by and I wondered for an
instant what they were there for and
then I remembered oh that's right the
presence in the car he was on my right
and Ralph was on my left but I forgot
for a minute that we were in a
president's car did you ever get
intimidated i am by lyndon b johnson or
anyone else that Ralph in you or that
you came to I don't think so I remember
remember watch that somebody was coming
to the house and I was very eager to
make the house look good when we were
married they marry Elizabeth had been
ill for years and the house just wasn't
in very good shape and I went to work on
it and this diplomat was coming and I
was trying very hard to be and get
everything just right and ralph said
Marilyn thorn so whoever it was it's
coming here to see me and he is very
eager to meet you and he's not coming
here to see this house so just calm down
in other words I thought that was funny
but I don't know he just get kind of get
used to that we had had lunch one day in
Washington with what was Warren's first
name the chief justice what was his
first name anyway wonderful Admiral
Admiral
and ralph said before we went said how
would you how would you like to have
lunch work just for heck of it I said
well what I really like to be with his
Adlai Stevenson / he had just died and I
said I'm sorry about that but that's who
I'd like to really meet and he said well
well well will decide on somebody else
and then the chief justice call me on
the telephone and wanted to speak to rap
and I thought I was gonna faint the RAF
had going down to get some sup at the
grocery store in Washington and I
remember being excited about that but
that was fun but I don't remember any
others being intimidated by I remember
we were at a reception once at the White
House and my walk out of the line and
the president kissed me and rob said he
looked funny what's the matter I said
the president kiss me he said what do
you expect him to do I didn't know that
was the routine but it was nice that's
all I think of ralph mcgill became
famous or infamous when he publicly
supported integration but at least at
first he was surprised to find that his
wife Marilyn Morgan stood by his side on
that contentious issue the showers are
really almost a generation after him and
I had read what he wrote all always and
I didn't I was happy for us to have
I didn't I was happy for us to be have
racial mixes of any kind that was no
problem he was a little bit surprised
because the lives of most of his friends
didn't want to entertain blacks but I
said look I'm younger than you I'm used
to it he said you're sure I said I'm
different I know that by that time you
were already very established in Atlanta
as a pediatric dentist did that change
your I guess now that changed her
independence it was a good marriage
because we were both really happy in
what we were doing and well felt secure
nobody neither one of us leaned on the
other one there's a very it was a very
short time but it was very happy Marilyn
Morgan has been involved with the
women's center at Emory since it was
founded in the 1990s in 1999 the women's
center began the annual mary lynn morgan
lectureship on women in the Health
Professions Ali crown the director of
what is now called the Center for Women
at Emory is also part of the pcs w's
oral history project how did that come
about when you being connected to the
women's center well I think there are I
think they are wonderful resourceful and
a resting place for women to talk freely
they have those flashes on financial
management you can go there nurse your
baby they have a splendid library Oh
what do you think is special about
having a space for women only to come
together well I think there's every
reason why that's good um
I think it's good for people and then do
it too I just think if you have some
place where you can just say whatever
you want to and not worry about
somebody's feelings it's just good for
you like you would a close friend you
can consider every woman in that group
as being a close friend and I going to
go tell anybody anything and and they're
not going to worry about they're just
going to try to be helpful and I think
that women center does a terrific job
yeah in terms of Emory today what do you
think makes the school work and how do
you think it's um how do you think it's
changed now that there are so many more
women in leadership positions or as
teachers or researchers or students well
it's changed a lot but I'm not sure it's
because women are there that they've
changed to accept them we should
certainly an intelligent thing to do and
but I know that the parts of the
University didn't used to do things
together and that was something that
generated one of his aim is that that
that would happen and Jim Wagner's just
he is so on fire about getting ever
getting top-notch professors and the
school is made progress in every way
because one of my personal pleasures is
how many african-americans we've got
nobody's criticizing anybody I just I
just think it's marvelous so you see
lots of changes but aren't just about
male female but also in terms of race
yeah and the caliber of our teachers is
just getting to be so great and the
cooperation and
everything it's just a darn good school
yeah so what's the highlight of your
involvement with emery if you had to
pick just one aspect i guess serving on
that board and knowing everybody knowing
what's going on I guess that's what I
really like and enjoying the people and
being able to see what I think it's just
been a marvelous experience and I think
it is for anybody who gets on there
another thing I've enjoyed about the
board is the incredibly fine men with
such integrity that I've gotten to know
and you can make a list of them both Lee
Jones it was a fantastic person he was
able to listen to dissenting opinions
around the table and he was able to get
up and make a statement and made
everybody happy thing you know they
thought they contributed in not many
people can do that not many leaders can
do it he could Jim lady is another one
you could trust them trust him anywhere
to do the right thing or think the right
thing and there's so many that I've
gotten to know it's just a rewarding
experience to be acquainted with men of
that caliber do you think that the board
and its dynamic have changed much of the
more women have come on to it
I don't know that the women have made
the changes but they certainly are
actually they certainly do contribute I
mean women can just do so many things
and there's no point and stopping them
they could just they can't do more than
a man can do what they can certainly do
as much if they've got if they're well
educated me and are bright they can do
anything what um what advice would you
give to women who want to go into a
field that they're not many women in or
who are trying to do something that not
many women have done what would you tell
them if they want to just do it yeah
that's not why is nobody with any sense
just gonna stop yeah just something that
you do um I saw that you wrote um or
said that you were rewarded in my
efforts to help build their self-esteem
as parents so too enjoyed their mothers
and was rewarded in my efforts to help
build their excuse me self-confidence as
parents so it sounds like you saw your
role not just as a dentist but it's
someone to help the parents as well is
that right now it it seems to me that
back back then parents didn't have a lot
of confidence I would tell her mother i
said look whatever i said i know a lot
about children i really do have read
about him and studied about him i said i
never had anything as it remember that
you should sift what i say for your
child you should do the same thing with
your pediatrician and the orthodontist
never
body else because you you really and you
know some of them just hadn't thought
about their having any input at all but
I just they had they just had to and to
learn to God I don't think mothers are
like that anymore but they used to be
kind of afraid to say anything what do
you think mothers are like now from what
you something I think they're a little
more willful about talking to a
physician or Oh Dennis questions as they
should I think what do you think has
helped women take on that new role as
mothers I just think women are smarter
mothers were smarter parents are smarter
I'm sure not all of them but the ones
that we know are I had a real ego trip a
couple of months ago I had a two men
were friends one of them had been my
patient when I'm had been my student and
they were so they took me out to lunch
and that was really fun the student said
to Bill when he was a student the
wonderful young man now he's a nice to
come down there to the doctors building
with my mother and my sister and I
always wanted to go first to get it over
with and he's I remember once I had a
cabin you said now this is going to hurt
but not more than you can stand so he
said then I got ready and he said first
it didn't hurt at all that hurt terribly
and then he said after I got through you
always made over me i was wondering too
yeah well he gave me a toys and gave me
stuff and told me I was brave and
wonderful and but anyway he was fun to
talk about his appointments where he
remember them and then must then the
students talked about our seminar
teaching how much he enjoyed that so it
was a real ego trip but I did think I
did enjoy teaching mothers and
explaining things to them and I thought
that was as important as taking care of
the children and what do you think it
was like for the mothers to to see you
with such confidence about how to take
care of their children well I just like
for them to know that I didn't know any
more related we had a mother one time we
died this past year of cancer and I
remember when her grown daughter growing
up now was four years old she said to
her mother her mother was kind of cross
she said mother mama what you need today
is is more loving I thought that kid at
four knows that I never forgot that I
was told her mother about that it as you
don't scare for euros say things as wise
is that two adults she was a cute little
girl looking for to Emory and at the
world in general what role do you think
women are going to play in the next 10
years or 20 years or how do you think
it's going to change well we can have a
woman president I mean so many of our
producers are so stupid and we're going
to learn that it's just possible that
one religions as good as another one
everybody has a basic need to worship
and they're going to make a religion and
we might as well be tolerant of all of
them you don't know whether yours is
better than the next guys or not and you
have to worship in the way you know
and use it or if you don't like it give
it up and do another one but it's sort
hard for a lot of people to do
you did it we'll just outgrow our
prejudices
I think I think we all feel sorry about
populations where the women are still
discriminated against and beaten up and
raped and worry about it but i think i'd
like to see the whole world change yeah
i'm thankful that we have the preceding
program is copyrighted by emory
university